speak to aam bin Javed who knows the
region very well been there several
times joins us here so let's just have a
look at the context of this we can bring
up a map here and to try and understand
the broader geographical picture and
where all this is going on and where the
targets were yes context is really
important and if you see on this map all
going all the way from Iran into Iraq
into Syria and then Lebanon is where
many of these groups have been operating
all the way from dalala to Salah uh to
Amar province where the anal Assad base
is where there have been a number of
attacks That Base which was hit by
ballistic missiles by Iran which houses
us Personnel towards alukal Alim on the
Iraqi side alukal on the Syrian side
where there is a presence of US forces
as well and and again in deror where US
forces are present and these militias
which are linked to Iran which have been
playing a crucial role in the fight
against iseland now part and parcel of
the security apparatus whether you look
at Iraq or Syria the popular mobile
ization forces being the biggest of them
known as the has Shi which are now
reporting to the Iraqi prime minister so
it is extremely significant to look at
it not just as the pretext of some armed
groups that are operating in desert
outposts these are groups which have
been backed some of been trained uh by
Iran some by the United States and
Coalition forces as well in the fight
against isil and now when this flares up
there is the warning of it escalating
you're already seeing four countries in
that picture you've already got the
theater of war expanding to Yemen and
all of these groups coming together
where the US insists that it is not at
war in the Middle East but it is
continuing to Target and we've already
heard just now from Mahmud saying that
there's retaliation taking place the US
says it's just the beginning there's
going to be more strikes coming so the
potential for this to expand is as you
say is is large absolutely and that is
what we've been hearing from various
Regional leaders the the government of
Iraq the government of Syria the
government of Jordan the the Turks the
GCC have all been warning against the
the potential for all of this to
escalate Beyond anybody's control
because many of these groups may be
ideologically or militarily linked to
Iran but it it is not clear how much
operational control does Iran have of
all of these groups and if they decide
and now you've seen a retaliation
because three us Personnel were killed
thousands of us Personnel are deployed
in these areas as you begin to see some
retaliatory measures could this escalate
into something further and again it's
not just the protection of US troops you
also have to look at for their zor for
instance there are thousands and
thousands of isil Fighters who are being
held by the SDF the Kurdish forces which
are backed by the United States in case
the US leaves in case there is a vacuum
as we've seen in other theaters of War
there could be other implications there
could be other outcomes as again uh
which will not be able to control by
anyone in this in this force and these
us strikes what actual impact do they
have on the the group's ability to act
well it appears to be a very measured
response you have not seen seen any uh
individuals being targeted uh major
areas in Iraq major cities the settled
cities have not been targeted these
strikes have uh conducted been conducted
in outposts uh in weapons Depots
infrastructures uh areas where there at
least there was some for warning of what
was going to come so it appears that the
US president had to respond he has
responded but he hasn't responded in a
way where it would uh you know start a
chain reaction of attacks and
counterattacks as we'd seen in the past
you've you not at the point yet where we
saw when kasim suani was murdered uh
that the Iranian resorted to bistic
missiles against us bases in Iraq I
don't think we've reached that precipice
yet but again this is a very fluid
active theater of war and any
miscalculation could have unintended
consequen Iran says of course it doesn't
want war but what does it want from
these militias well it you see in the
last decade or so in the fight against
Isel yes there has been a US Coalition
that has been operating in that area but
all of these groups which were heading
the operations especially in Iraq were
uh troops on the ground uh is fight
against isol done by militias which were
backed by Iran ideologically aligned to
Iran uh so Iran is not going to it has
now essentially control from tan all the
way into Iraq into Syria and to Lebanon
uh so Iran has this unprecedented
influence in the last few decades that
it now has groups on the ground with
weapons in their hands it is not going
to give up give them up easily the US
wants to go after them it has been
trying to go after them with its troops
in the on the ground uh but again now
that tempers are high uh emotions are
high with the situation in Gaza a lot of
unrest in these countries where
thousands and thousands of protesters
have been coming out to protest against
them as well so it will not be uh
suitable moment for these countries even
if they wanted to go after these groups
uh it would not be the time and it could
again have unintended consequences oama
that's a great context for us thanks
very much indeed for that been JV here
thank you